[Musique]
c'est une soirée incandescente qui
commence dans un instant avec l'une des
voies les plus cristallines de la
chanson française femme piano devenu
femme orchestre à la chanter sur presque
toutes les scènes de France et s'apprête
à brûler le feu ce soir à l'accord Arena
mais aussi sur les antennes Canal+
puisque son concert il sera retransmis
en direct on vous vend la mèche Juliette
Armanet est en aparté
bonsoir Juliette
bienvenue bonsoir ça me fait toujours
rire quand même de ce principe de
mission est quand même fier
que vous ayez le sourire en effet et
alors c'est rigolo parce que juste avant
l'entrée je vous entends des fredonnée
à cette chanson de Françoise Hardy qui
s'appelle première rencontre où elle dit
je restais seule dans ma chambre je
restais à ça dans ma chambre parce que
comme j'allais être seul dans cet
endroit je pensais à ça vous vous
souvenez un peu de l'ambiance je me
souviens mais là il y a voilà il y a
plein de nouveaux
vous avez il y a plein de nouveaux trucs
là évidemment pour l'épisode 2 c'est
sympa
c'est marrant vous avez pas vu les
patins à roulettes si c'est la première
chose que j'ai vu
en arrivant ils sont incroyables sinon
il y a les patins à glace en fait on
voulait installer une sorte de corner
patinoire pour pouvoir faire une démo
façon souriez
votre clip bien sûr cette ambiance la
boule à facette également elle est là
c'est vrai que vous avez fait du patin à
glace aussi j'ai fait du patin à glace
pendant quelques années c'était un peu
ouais comme une sorte de sport études
j'y allais tous les matins j'adorais ça
j'ai doré le bruit de la lame sur la
glace le froid le look
et puis c'est pas c'est un sport qui
mêle la grâce à la vitesse et ça c'est
un truc qui me plaît bien qui est un
truc comme ça de petit bolide de vitesse
de un peu de danger et en même temps un
truc comme ça de danse et puis j'étais
moi très très fan de Surya Bonali et
j'avais les patins dédicacés de par
Cyria Benali donc
bien entendu alors ce concert pas de
patinoire pour l'instant mais des
flammes de l'incandescence de
l'evanescence aussi de l'entrain du rock
ça va pulser à la coarena à Paris
évidemment ah oui oui c'est un mot
complètement hasbin hein c'est ça ok
merci
ce sera diffusé là dans quelques minutes
sur CANAL+ juste après nous on va
quasiment vous téléporter sur la scène
de l'accord Arena à Paris vous êtes dans
quel état
je vais pas vous mentir j'ai peur en
même temps
j'ai eu un je sais pas
j'ai regardé une vidéo j'ai retrouvé une
vidéo de quand je chantais il y a 10 ans
l'amour en solitaire ma toute première
elle a toute première fois que je
chantais cette chanson devant des gens
et je sais pas ça m'a rassuré parce que
j'ai l'impression que je suis dans le
même état qui a 10 ans enfin j'ai
toujours ce trac là je me sens toujours
aussi fait brille mais le désir et le
même il a fait que croître et puis en
fait les gros gros paquebots comme ça et
de Bercy je pense qu'il faut les prendre
aussi avec comme ça enfin je dis ça je
j'essaye de me rassurer mais je sais pas
j'ai l'impression qu'il faut essayer
aussi de crever le gros ballon là en se
disant bon ça reste quand même un
concert je crois que le public autant
que nous on a tous envie qu'il y ait une
rencontre on a envie de se rencontrer on
a envie de partager quelque chose donc a
priori
ça se passera bien après je suis pas à
l'abri de me casser une jambe de glisser
sur une peau j'ai fait tout l'inventaire
des trucs qui pouvaient hyper mal se
passer un piano qui qui explose qui
s'arrête je me casse une jambe bon il y
a un million de trucs possibles il y a
aussi la possibilité que ça se passe
très bien vous disiez du haut de mon mec
58 je vais pas me la jouer Lady Gaga
c'est pas moi et puis et puis cette
simplicité que que vous avez a priori
mais on sent que là il y a une liberté
une envie d'être troc totalement et de
j'allais dire d'être dans l'audace bah
sans doute parce que ce disque là il
appelait ça il appelait quelques il
appelle ça il appelle un truc
plus flamboyant plus extraverti plus
plus
orchestrale donc il y a plus cette enfin
il y a cette intimité au piano bien sûr
mais il y a aussi un un truc plus
déployé on est 7 sur scène voilà il y a
8 claviers il y a deux stands de
percussion il y a du saxophone bon donc
il y a aussi quelque chose c'est très
musical c'est il y a quelque chose
d'assez sauvage on a très peu de bandes
de clics on joue vraiment à l'instinct
au feeling c'est très vivant voilà donc
comme musique donc je sais pas du coup
ça donne envie d'être dans un dans un
relâchement du corps quoi mais bon je me
regarde pas trop enfin dès que je
regarde des trucs je ça me je me dis bon
tu regardes pas parce que ça peut être
inhibant non mais ça peut être Inno
parce que en fait en vérité moi je fais
les choses comme je le sens et et voilà
mais sur regarder ça peut on peut se
dire ouh là c'est grotes donc je suis
désolé je vous informe je vais vous
infliger quand même de voir un extrait
parce que nous on en raffole je voudrais
qu'on regarde la flamme on regarde et on
écoute OK
[Musique]
allumer la feuille comme
j'aime pas
pas
les mains
ins
ce sentiment en moi ne me lasse pas le
choix je te déclare ma flamme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui c'est incandescence et puissance
et la flamme c'est sur la scène des
Victoires de la Musique vous avez été
récompensé aussi c'est ardent on l'a
compris comment comment vous fonctionnez
avec le public je suis
j'ai l'impression d'être de les regarder
j'ai envie de regarder tout le monde
j'ai envie de voir tout le monde bon
maintenant les salles sont un peu plus
grandes donc il me faudrait des jumelles
pour pouvoir voir chaque je sais pas
j'ai envie de me dire comment cette
personne là pourquoi elle est là ce soir
pourquoi toi tu es venu qu'est-ce qui
t'amène là qu'est-ce qui t'a plu
une chanson qu'est-ce que vous faites si
elle n'était pas prévue sur sur cette
scène là ça dépend si je si j'ai pas
trop peur de la jouer je la joue mais
fais attention au public et un dictateur
aussi il faut savoir ce faut savoir ce
franchir ça franchit on peut pas être
que la marionnette du public il y a
quelque chose de à trouver de serein et
puis et puis faut oser aussi décevoir
enfin j'écris par exemple les ce qu'on
appelle les talks j'écris entre les
chansons j'ai des petits j'ai des petits
bouts de phrases mais j'essaye d'être
alors il y a des soirs où c'est des
carrément c'est des peaux de bananes je
dis vraiment des trucs des blagues on a
tous fait des blagues qui tombent à plat
voilà
c'est vérité
en tout cas c'est ce qui m'intéresse
Juliette Armanet la tournée elle est
conséquente vous avez passé des mois sur
les routes comment vous vous préparez
accepter une forme de vide cet espace
qui va arriver après parce que c'est ça
forcément on retombe on revient un
quotidien écoutez sincèrement je sais
pas parce que la dernière fois que j'ai
arrêté une tournée j'ai un enfant qui
est arrivé dans mes bras deux semaines
après donc voilà donc j'ai fait au
revoir paris c'est parti donc je sais
pas du tout comment je vais accepter ce
vide j'imagine que comme dans il va y
avoir du vertige en même temps quand je
vois tous les livres là
que vous avez mis voilà tout ce que je
vois là-bas
je me dis quand même que il y a pas
enfin il y a de quoi remplir ce vide
c'est à dire qu'il y a aussi un moment
où entre soi et soi-même on commence un
petit peu à avoir fait le tour et je
pense que le le
bonheur vient des autres vient de des
livres enfin qui nous racontent d'autres
choses que soi parce qu'il y a un moment
donné ou voilà c'est un vrai des autres
c'est intéressant parce que je voulais
vous demander une petite chose j'ai cru
comprendre que vous étiez une grande
insatisfaite enfin en tout cas vous
mettiez la barre très haut et quitte a
parfois usé votre entourage voir vous
user vous-même clairement ça se traduit
comment
j'ai fait je pense pour chaque chanson
j'ai fait une quinzaine de versions de
chaque chanson
je suis capable d'aller refaire une
prise de voix à deux heures d'un
mastering parce que j'estime que je suis
pas allé au bout
oui il y a une forme de comment dire de
de je pense c'est pas que de
l'insatisfaction c'est peut-être une une
peur de pas être plus juste de pas être
au plus près de l'os de pas être dans la
vérité
et puis la question de l'inache fait de
façon il y a forcément un moment où il
faut accepter que qu'une œuvre est
inachevée quoi qu'il arrive et que le
public fait qu'elle s'achève c'est c'est
mathématique ou ça va plutôt crescendo
je me soigne je me soigne je crois que
là cette tournée m'a quand même parce
que là maintenant je travaille avec
beaucoup de musiciens sur scène et je
sens qu'il y a des moments où il faut
lâcher
voilà donc je suis obligée alors est-ce
que que vous lâchez quand vous avez des
sucreries en bouche ou un bon livaro par
exemple je vous vois venir mais c'est
parce que j'ai grillé qu'il y avait des
dragibus bien sûr cette escale des noirs
on a été précis c'est cela c'est
toujours cela je vais en manger
directement
bon alors maintenant vous êtes bien avec
ces mini biquets collant ou au fond des
poches c'est au choix je vous laisse
vous avez de l'eau bien sûr Juliette si
vous voulez je vais rester comme ça on
passe devant biote vite fait ouais biote
c'est évidemment votre construction
aussi votre famille ouais c'est marrant
ça fait bizarre parents
bah ouais c'est c'est
je regarde avec émotion parce qu'il est
question qu'on
qu'on se sépare de la maison en question
donc voilà bon c'est des choses très
personnelles mais je sais pas non c'est
un village dans lequel j'ai j'ai grandi
et maintenant d'y voir mon fils jouer au
ballon dans les ruelles de cette de
cette de cette petite ville je sais pas
c'est moi j'aime je suis vraiment comme
je sais pas cette chanson de Christophe
qui s'appelait petite fille du soleil
j'ai l'impression que je viens de là
vous voulez vous installer au fauteuil
gris ouais
là alors
Juliette évidemment
profitez-en la télécommande à droite
comme la saison dernière vous appuyez
sur n'importe quel bouton OK
j'étais facile
vu tomber dans mes bras
je promenais ton ville
[Musique]
de la douche est
a cette façon que tu avais de te serrer
entre le revers de mon smoke qui me
manque
je l'ai jamais retrouvé
le soleil
[Musique]
je ne t'oublie pas
de ses deux voix cette voix cristalline
la vôtre et celle de Christophe Sedan
dit en clair obscur disparait en 2020
c'était juste un an avant quasiment au
chantier ensemble à Dolce Vita
j'imagine que c'était un moment fou pour
vous qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça vous
procure et puis et puis qu'est-ce que ça
dit de vous aussi ce duo cette chanson
j'avais complètement oublié que
Christophe et moi vous avez à peu près
la même taille et ce jour-là il était
venu avec une panoplie de veste parce
qu'il faisait ses propres vestes et tout
customiser et que du coup il m'avait
filé sa veste donc
du coup j'avais savais c'est lui il
avait la même en noir et blanc et
bah en fait c'est marrant parce que la
dolce vita voilà je la jouais à Biot je
l'ai joué cette chanson sur le piano de
ma famille pendant des années sans
évidemment connaître Christophe voilà et
et c'est une chanson phare de ma vie de
mon répertoire et voilà quand j'ai
rencontré Christophe il y a voilà je
évidemment tout de suite jouer cette
chanson en disant mais pour moi c'est la
folie et voilà et ce qui était super
c'est que c'était un Taratata je devais
on devait travailler avec Christophe
j'étais allé chez lui avec donc hyper
tard évidemment ce qui travaille la nuit
et en fait on n'a pas du tout au travail
manger des olives on a discuté il m'a
fait écouter des sons et tout et puis à
un moment donné tu es une heure du matin
je dis mais Christophe faut peut-être
qu'on travaille
bien ouais vas-y joue un truc et puis on
a joué on a joué une fois il m'a dit ah
c'est super on fera ça demain et moi
j'étais mais
tétanisé et c'était tellement belle
leçon de
liberté de se dire ce qui arrivera à ce
moment là c'est ce qui doit arriver de
ce qu'on a à dire tous les deux je
voudrais que vous appuyez sur le bouton
ouais bien sûr vous êtes une grande
lectrice aussi
alors comment cette idée justement de
narration qui obtient un grand succès
vous est venu
d'abord c'est sur des années que cette
c'était l'idée de faire une
autobiographie collective en fait c'est
ça c'est à dire qu'il soit pas une une
histoire de ma vie
qui ne soit pas l'histoire de Papa Maman
etc d'abord parce que tout ça j'en ai
déjà parlé dans d'autres livres mais qui
puisse prendre en compte le monde autour
de moi le monde tel qu'il a évolué tel
que je l'ai vu changer et tel qu'il nous
accompagne tous c'est ça parce que on
n'est pas isolé du tout on a à chaque
moment le monde qui nous entoure et
c'est cela au fond que je voulais
retrouver j'allais dire de
d'année en année exactement mais de
période en période
on a voulu aussi raconter vos influences
en 2008 c'est vrai que elle convoque
l'universel dans le récit singulier moi
j'ai fait mon mémoire de lettres sur
l'autobiographie donc c'est vraiment le
cœur de toutes mes réflexions et pour
moi et à l'époque où j'ai fait mon
mémoire je connaissais pas j'avais pas
lu les années et j'ai découvert les
années bien plus tard comme tout le
reste de l'oeuvre de Annie Arnaud et je
pense que pour beaucoup de femmes
notamment c'est un
choc de découvrir à quel point Annie un
Noah a su parler de du corps des femmes
du tabou des femmes de la place des
femmes
avec voilà une singularité tellement
tellement poignante et impudique et cru
à la fois enfin j'étais un génie
vraiment et les années c'est un livre
qui m'a complètement
retourné la tête parce que c'est
exactement ce qu'elle dit c'est très
très beau parce que elle part du
principe que le récit que l'on fait de
soi ne peut jamais être que
circonstanciel que ce qu'on croit être
on a une illusion de liberté on croit
tous être libre mais en vérité tout ce
qui se passe autour de nous et joue
complètement dans notre manière de vivre
et d'être au monde c'est absolument
génial c'est un immense livre
de femmes vous quand vous êtes devenu
maman d'Abel il y a 5 ans maintenant je
pense que le compte est bon ça a été
aussi pour vous un accompagnement ses
livres son écriture sa féminité ce
féminisme aussi bien sûr bien sûr que
Annie Ernaux m'a aidé à voir plus clair
en moi-même moi j'ai l'impression de me
que ma libération
elle a été très très très très lente
quoi très très très lente et que j'ai
été aidé par des écrivains vers des
autrices comme ami Arnaud un nier un
homme a aidé à me libérer à me
rencontrer à me connaître
le fait de devenir maman et le fait de
devenir mère oui c'était quelque chose
que je désirais depuis très longtemps
depuis toujours et je le redoutais à la
fois et voilà rien de dire cette phrase
c'est pas si facile à dire et ça a été
un grand grand chamboulement de tous
mélanger de tout vivre de vivre à la
fois cette vie de scène cette vie
d'amour cette vie de de voyage cette vie
de création parce que il y a aussi des
choses une fois qu'on devient mère
est-ce qu'on peut autant parler de soi
avec autant de liberté c'est aussi ça
une vraie question est-ce que je vais
continuer à pouvoir parler maintenant
que j'ai une responsabilité familiale
maintenant que j'ai construit quelque
chose autour de moi il y a des regards
là-dessus est-ce que je vais pouvoir
rester aussi libre dans ce que j'ai à
dire ça ça a été un vrai truc à un
moment donné il faut savoir s'affranchir
de ça et se dire bah j'ai plusieurs mois
j'ai plusieurs vies mais elle est en une
et je cherche à ne renoncer à aucune je
dis pas que c'est facile
Juliette évidemment on ne vous écoute
avec attention il y a beaucoup de
poésies dans ce que vous racontez
beaucoup de réalisme aussi il y a un
temps important dans votre histoire
parce que vous n'avez pas toujours été
une artiste sur scène vous avez aussi
été journaliste pendant 7 ans je crois
c'est pas rien vous avez même réalisé un
documentaire je voudrais si vous êtes
d'accord si vous êtes d'accord seulement
de rester
vous me direz d'accord on fait à votre
guise en tout cas il faut toujours en
passer par la télécommande ah oui
toujours cette histoire on dirait une
calculette
[Musique]
la musique au départ avec maman
et elle joue très bien de la musique
c'est toi qui lui a appris alors
je suis très contente alors
s'assure et si Paulette oublie parfois
jusqu'à son propre nom elle s'est encore
parfaitement me dire quand je fais des
fausses notes
comme si de rien n'était
étrangement il lui reste encore ce coin
de paradis
tu veux plus qu'il y en ait nous jouons
aujourd'hui un jour mon prince viendra
Paulette me donne un cours magistral
c'est
celui-là que tu joues tes mains tremble
mais son oreille elle est
miraculeusement intacte
c'est un documentaire que j'ai choisi de
faire
à un moment de
de la vie de ma grand-mère qui était un
basculement parce que ma grand-mère
était une super excellente pianiste et
elle n'a jamais elle en a jamais fait sa
vie mais c'était toute sa vie et elle a
transmis l'amour de la musique à ma mère
à qui elle donnait des cours tous les
matins avant d'aller à l'école et ma
mère m'a appris à jouer au piano ainsi
ton père bref et à ce moment-là de sa
vie ma grand-mère a eu cette maladie
d'Alzheimer qui était une maladie voilà
bon bah c'est une maladie horrible mais
il y avait c'était un point de
basculement il y avait il y avait plus
elle se souvenait plus de rien de son
nom de son prénom doux qui elle était
est-ce qu'elle avait eu des enfants
est-ce que
elle devenait complète moi elle-même son
rapport au monde était complètement
fluide c'était son territoire de
conscience et son territoire de liberté
et ça m'a fasciné de voir que cette
femme qui disait fourchette à la place
de bonjour qui avait la raie dans le
mauvais sens et qui se souvenait même
plus de son propre prénom gardait ce
territoire là que la musique restait
envers et contre tout son endroit de
résistance c'était incroyable on avait
envie c'est une forme de devoir de
mémoire de lui rendre hommage à Paulette
à travers ce documentaire que vous aviez
signé les petits enfants d'Alzheimer
parce que c'est vrai vous avez eu cette
vieille journaliste aussi à quel moment
vous vous sentez que c'est la musique
bonne question parce que en fait
moi j'ai toujours fait de la musique je
suis née dans ma famille je suis née
dans un je suis pratiquement on est dans
un piano ils ont ouvert le piano ils ont
dit tiens elle est là et voilà mes
parents sont rencontrés ce sont aimés
s'aiment autour d'un piano autour de la
musique donc en fait en vérité la
musique je me suis jamais dit tiens
aujourd'hui ma vie c'est la musique ma
vie ça a toujours été la musique j'ai
grandi dans la musique
je crois par contre comme je vous disais
que j'ai mis du temps à me rencontrer
avec la question du féminisme de la
féminité et de la Libération je pense
que c'est exactement pareil
pour la musique j'ai mis beaucoup de
temps à ce que les planètes s'alignent à
ce que finalement ce que je chante soit
vraiment à moi à me défaire de toutes
les influences j'ai vu qu'il y avait
bjorque par là-bas bon voilà il y a il
faut il m'a fallu du temps pour me
rencontrer il m'a fallu beaucoup de
temps pour me rencontrer et le temps que
j'ai pris à faire tous ces documentaires
n'a pas été du tout un temps perdu parce
que c'était un temps très habité
passionnant et finalement c'était
c'était pas une salle d'attente c'était
un moment aussi d'éducation sentimentale
quoi mais j'emmenais mon clavier dans
toutes les dans tous les dans tous les
avions dans toutes les voitures où
j'allais
mais je sentis à la trentaine voilà
comme quoi il y a pas il est jamais trop
tard pourquoi que ce soit j'ai senti que
j'étais prête et j'ai pris le temps de
de faire le tour du sujet avant de me
lancer Juliette voulait bien vous
déplacer certainement alors évidemment
vous connaissez la première bibliothèque
c'est plutôt des objets la seconde ce
sont vos influences en termes de livres
de DVD de disques également
là j'ai des beaux souvenirs agréables ce
petit feu
Juliette Armanet au rayon Musique on
vous a proposé une petite sélection
des Beach Boys et puis à droite aussi de
l'aplatine l'étagante dessous
je sais pas c'est un des plus grands
albums du monde ouais de Bjork déjà
cette pochette est folle est-ce que vous
voulez
nous proposer bio qu'elle écoute ou un
autre titre
Queens tout ce que vous voulez ah bah
oui regarde presque qu'est-ce que je
vais vous mettre
Vénus
[Musique]
c'est marrant parce que je l'avais
travaillé parce que mon père est
pianiste enfin a fait beaucoup de jazz
et on travaillait l'action one in love
dans le New Real Book qui est la bible
des jazzman elle est incroyable cette
platine elle est méga
mega moderne
[Musique]
j'avais oublié
ça c'est bien
[Musique]
nous on a un cadeau pour vous Juliette
je crois vous allez voir la boîte se
trouve à l'angle du canapé des cadeaux
j'adore ça ah oui
je l'ai repéré je vous mens pas je l'ai
repéré en arrière
alors la dernière fois vous m'aviez
offert un petit dauphin je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez
alors attendez
oh génial nous avons parce que vous avez
effectivement travaillé et fait votre
mémoire de Master dessus Romain Gary
génial mais j'ai écouté une interview de
Pavlovic voilà justement récemment ce
cousin qui s'est fait passer pour Émile
Ajar justement il signe tous immortel
merci c'est génial
évidemment bah c'est une entourloupe de
folie qui serait capable de faire ça
aujourd'hui c'est absolument incroyable
alors ça c'est le premier cadeau le
deuxième c'est parce que votre votre
histoire votre patrimoine familial
compte on ne peut plus et ça s'appelle
la lignée c'est un carnet de famille
pour explorer votre histoire familiale
garder une trace du passé sécher carnet
goguette c'est une création française
signée Sophie Gautier vous pourrez
composer avec Abel et raconter à la fois
vos souvenirs vos traits divers et
variés Alain à l'autre merci merci
beaucoup nous on a envie d'une petite
photo
bien sûr bien sûr à gauche dans la
bibliothèque cette fois de gauche à
gauche
je suis contente en tout cas de voir
cette photo là avec Amélie Bonin et oui
César du meilleur court-métrage quand
même ça aussi c'est un axe que vous
développez la carrière cinématographique
je suis très fière pour cette femme
parce que elle a fait un discours qui
était absolument magnifique pendant les
Césars elle a dit il y a pas que Mbappé
qui peut ramener la coupe à la maison on
peut on peut avoir des cheveux blancs
deux enfants avoir 40 ans et sentir
qu'on est au commencement des choses
puis elle a eu ce César et c'est
absolument génial
pour partir un jour bien sûr Juliette
une petite photo alors je vous explique
le principe il y a une petite pastille
Orange vous pouvez appuyer dessus pour
allumer d'abord l'appareil ensuite une
petite télécommande mini décidément
c'était comment vous aimez bien ça
et là vous êtes prêtes
parfait des sacrés vous avez des sacrés
trucs
justement pas banal n'oubliez pas vos
cadeaux non et effectivement le truc pas
banal c'est que quand vous allez faire
quelque part ça c'est pour nous Juliette
la photo ah oui effectivement j'ai
peut-être pas garder une photo de moi je
vous la laisse avec les dragibus je
pique un régime
pas votre petit paquet
Juliette c'est effectivement la magie en
aparté vous allez faire quelque part
encore vers la porte que vous avez
emprunté cette ce chemin que vous avez
emprunté à l'aller que vous parcourez de
nouveau vous allez ouvrir la porte et
téléportation immédiates sur la scène de
l'accord Arena où vous êtes dans votre
public c'est en direct
plus on vous attend sur scène de les
mettre le feu merci Juliette Armanet le
concert d'Emma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]